and it's been a while may 23rd the last
time zach was on the rubber he is four
and three in his 10 starts four one four
in his 58 two thirds innings 38
strikeouts
so and he is uh dealing
against the kansas city royals has
always pitched well 5-0 in his career
with a 183 earned run average let's hold
that stance as well tonight
[Music]
that a boy shallow right
harold ramirez
makes the catch one down
now the catcher the all-star salvador
perez
is ninth in the american league in
homer's with 20. salvador perez goes
down hacking here though and a great
first inning and zach flisack's return
danny making start number 11.
his 2.60 era remains the fifth best in
the american league for pitchers
throwing a minimum of 50 innings overall
4-3 record 2.6 era
52 innings 17 runs allowed 15 earned 18
walks 57 strikeouts
and a slide step and an elevated
fastball takes care of hernandez
michael taylor the center fielder steps
to the plate the pitch
swinging a shot to third inside the bag
down the left field line taylor can
motor he'll head to second easily and
he'll be in standing with a double top
of the order in whitt maryfield
whit gets a high fastball and he gets it
by rosario
so taylor will score
and whit merrifield
puts an end to a one for 20.
santana switch hitter left side and how
good does that feel carlos santana goes
deep to right field that is just his
second hit all year against the indians
and he puts the royals in front two
nothing in the fourth inning was a no
doubter you can't hit a ball better than
that at curveball he waited nicely
hunter dozier lined a left in the second
inning and the one two and a breaking
ball hit well deep left field that's way
back and that's gone a home run
over the high wall in left field hunter
dozier the second home run of the inning
it's his eighth home run of the year and
the royals lead this game three nothing
well bobby bradley drew the first walk
bradley bombs one to deep right field
that one's not coming back way out of
here
his ninth home run of the year gets the
indians on the board here in the fourth
only the sixth home run allowed by danny
duffy on the season
and it's a big two out hit
two on one out 3-1 royals in the fifth
long run salvi long run santana and
carlos santana
with a freight train coming at him is
able to hold his concentration and make
the play
man i can exhale now
and hold your breath seeing salvia
and santana closing in on that foul ball
at full speed and that was a close one
here's the 1-0 swung on and there's a
high fly ball to left not deep coming in
is ben and tendy and the left fielder
makes the catch to retire the side
frustrating inning for the indians as
they do not score we'll head to the
sixth three to one
royals in front
indians at first and second two down in
the eighth it's a three to one kansas
city lead and roberto perez has flied
out grounded out twice grandma reyes at
second base bobby bradley down at first
two down
2-1 pitch
high fly ball center field that goes
taylor he's out of room it's out of here
how good does that feel for roberto
perez as he tears around the bases
on two out three run homer
and the indians have flipped it and
taken a 4-3 lead
that's just what they needed
they were waiting for that one hit
and here it comes a spinner
and he takes it to right center field
and he got it all that's his power there
he knew it
[Applause]
james karen check now he is the indians
closure he'll face carlos santana
santana hits it into right center field
that is gone to tie the game carlos
santana with his second of the night
against his former team to tie it and
give the heartbeat back to the royals
what a swing he got the barrel on that
amazing they stayed with the fastball we
didn't see one big curve they thought
they could get him out with it
and
if we got a whole new game
well here we go bottom of the night and
kansas city's greg holland
line drive right field base hit all the
way into the corner cesar's off to the
races he'll pull into second base with a
one out double and the winning run is in
scoring position
[Applause]
that's what we're talking about rally
caps in place
two outs now what do they do here
yeah that's what i figured you're not
gonna let ramirez beat you
here is fred mill with a chance to win
it
the pitch swung on hit high hip deep to
left center
[Applause]
and the indians have their sixth
walk-off win
the third time via a home run
and fran mill the biggest man on the
team
is just getting pulverized and home
plate pulled the hands in hit a high
fastball and as strong as he is
he walked it off
how about two three run homers in the
back-to-back inning
about that
roberto perez did it with two outs in
the eighth inning
fred mill reyes does it with two out in
the ninth inning
and the indians stopped their nine game
losing streak